hey this is Eddie from kama AI and I
just wanted to do a quick video tutorial
on putting your sheet inserts into your
3d printed company okay so we got four
of the m3 inserts and one of the m2
inserts let's get started I got my
soldering iron set it's a 350 C about
I'm going to take the m31 and you want
to put the the edge that has a lip into
the plastic it's also it's smaller on
that end it's tapered so when you push
it in and won't pull out you kind of
want to set that in the back hole and
then just take your soldering iron
slowly heat it up and apply some force
downwards into the plastic eventually
you'll start to see it move into it and
it's pushing down you want to get it
flush so that the mount will sit flat on
the case and that looks like it's in
there pretty good the bottom piece same
thing you want to get the the smaller
tapered end in the hole pushed down
[Music]
you're gonna apply a good amount of
force to get them in and just kind of
wiggle them around until they start to
move and I'm flush with the plastic boom
do the same for the mount
and these these things start strong
we've tested trying to pull them out
it's really not possible they have a
gnarled edge that that really clings the
plastic it's gonna hang in there
all right all the big ones are done
let's do this tiny guy which goes in
back of the bottom this one's a little
easier to tell which side to put it in
there's a big gnarled edge on the top
that you want closer to the surface I'm
gonna set that in there you see that I
just popped it in there do the same
thing this one since it's so much
smaller heats up a lot quicker and
should not take as much force as the Big
M 3 heated inserts one of you guys can
see but you still want to get a flush
with the edge of the plastic that's best
you can I have this flat tip soldering
iron I'm gonna take this pointed edge
and kind of to get a better flush
surface with the plastic you could use
any kind of soldering iron and just push
it in the middle yeah that's about it
hope this is helpful